hey guys welcome to max Tech and this
right here is the world's most powerful
laptop for gaming
it's the razor blade studio edition and
in this video we're gonna play call of
duty modern warfare at 4k resolution to
see how much FPS we can get and we're
also gonna hook this up to apples 6k Pro
display XDR and actually play at 6k
resolution which is insane because it's
two and a half times harder to run than
4k this laptop right here actually got a
higher score in Unigine seven gaming
benchmark then our $15,000 Mac Pro with
the Vega 2 graphics
now this laptops meant for studio work
like video editing or graphics rendering
but who says we can't enjoy some games
on it so let's get right into it alright
guys here we are in the graphics
settings we could see full screen Quadra
our TX 5000 we've got the render
resolution at 4k right there the
framerate limit is set to 250 right
there
Nvidia highlights is off our texture
resolutions we've got everything right
there on high and a bunch of these extra
settings are on like the shadow map
resolution is on extra ultra for the
particle lighting anti-aliasing is on
these are pretty high settings so we
might have to tone them down a little
bit because it's a lot for 4k so let's
go ahead and try it out
these fans are definitely kicking up you
guys can probably hear them but it's
actually a lot of graphics power in this
thing get around 50 FPS on average
got that guy oh I was close so 50 FPS at
4k with a lot of the settings very high
it's pretty impressive
barely got that dude what guy was
running oh ok see that oh man yeah it's
not too bad
okay so average around 50 fps it's
actually pretty consistent let's turn
down the settings and see if we can get
60 at a minimum back in the graphics
let's turn the shadows to a normal SSR
we'll just go normal we'll turn off the
anti-aliasing because honestly we're at
4k resolution it's gonna look fine turn
the textures down to normal right here
and let's apply alright now we got a
daytime map right here playing some team
deathmatch and we're at 72 FPS right
here look at that
see an occasional dip sometimes drops to
54 but overall it's decent
got one guy right there mostly staying
above sixty but it does drop a little
bit sometimes all right I saw a guy
right here
got him so what I'm gonna do now is turn
down a couple of the other settings down
a little bit lower so I just noticed
that particle lighting is still at Ultra
I'm gonna set it to normal and let's see
if we could get a little bit more FPS
all right so now I'm seeing 75 77 78 84
yeah not bad I'm getting pretty good FPS
right now yeah Adam Oh almost had that
guy now obviously everything looks
absolutely excellent at this resolution
it looks great getting pretty good FPS I
haven't seen it drop down below 60 at
all now that we turn that last setting
off got that guy got him seeing 78 FPS
80 FPS it's kind of insane we're getting
this much at 4k on a laptop
No what am I supposed to do in that
situation man come on bro would you
think there you go guys getting
excellent FPS at 4k this is insane for a
laptop Oh
now before we hook up that pro display
XD are in play at 6 K we're actually
gonna turn it down to around 1440 P
around two and a half K that's 2560 by
1600 because the scaling isn't perfect
all right so here we are at around 2.5 k
look at that we're getting a hundred 30
FPS 146 nice whoa gotcha
what are you doing bro all right I'm
actually gonna turn up everything as
high as I possibly can let's see a
hundred 99 88 fps getting excellent fps
with everything turned on at 2.5 k let
me add one more thing where is this at
Direct X ray tracing let's see how this
goes Wow look at that 60 FPS right there
70 FPS staying above 60 as far as I
could tell
behind you bro now with that let's
connect it to the pro display HDR and
here it is all set up I got the laptop
and clamshell mode I got a bluetooth
mouse keyboard and right there you can
see six thousand sixteen by 33 84 so now
that we've got a resolution set to 6k
right there I'm gonna go ahead and turn
down a lot of these settings let's go
normal on these guys turn some of this
off shadow maps normal particle lighting
normal turn off these shadows turn off
ray tracing definitely turn this off
alright here we are
everything looks insane it is so
detailed right now with 6k resolution
it's crazy we're at about 35 FPS what
this guy just ran past me alright bro
boom so we're at around 35 FPS gadem
you've got to remember that 6k is two
and a half times harder than 4k it is a
ton of pixels so 35 FPS actually isn't
that bad what is this
ah come on yeah this is definitely not a
good gaming experience there's quite a
bit of motion blur because I'm just not
getting enough frames dad oh what's up
bro oh come on all right back in the
graphics settings let's turn this down
to 5k to see if we could get 60fps so it
actually didn't go up by much we're
sitting around 46 45 fps it's definitely
not much more oh I'm so lucky I got that
dude oh that triple kill oh come on that
guy let's ran past me right there
yes finally nice spring break whoo got
him you know what let's play at 4k with
this awesome display see if we can get
above 60fps again oh come on bro ya got
him right so right now we're getting
about 80 FPS but it does dip down quite
often now the reason we're getting less
FPS with this display is because it does
take some graphics power to connect and
power this crazy display whoa oh you
thought you had me bro what about you
you too oh we knifed me yeah
yes gotcha
alright guys there you have it that was
four or five and six K gaming on the
razorblade studio edition with the
protis play XD art now I know we weren't
able to get good frame eights at 6 K but
honestly what machine can we're able to
get a consistent over 60 FPS at 4k which
is really really good for this laptop
now if you guys are curious about the
different specs in pricing on this
laptop we'll have some links down in the
video description below and if you
haven't yet seen our review of this
laptop or a comparison to the 16 inch
macbook pro you guys will find those
videos right over there and if you
haven't yet subscribed click that circle
above to do so right now thank you guys
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]